we saw what can clearly be described as
an unusual cabinet meeting yesterday
with each of his secretaries praising
him saying it's an honor and a blessing
to serve etc who organized it this way
and why did they do this well it was an
extraordinary bath of adulation I I'm
not sure what the organizing principle
was it was clearly a public relations
effort to bolster the presidency what's
interesting is I mean not only imagine
if that were used to talk about the
agenda for the Forgotten man that the
president ran on to talk about the
opioid crisis to talk about things that
were being done for the people that
elected him as opposed to just merely
offering praise after praise well in
fact the president himself said never
has there been a president with few
exceptions who's passed more legislation
who's done more things that's just not
true there isn't a major piece of
legislation that's been passed he well
there are the pieces of legislation to
the extent the big ones that have passed
are ones that basically were passed
through the Congressional review Act
which is basically something that they
had pre-loaded before this presidency so
on his big agenda items they have not
come through and that's right this is a
another claim that bares some challenge
John Dickerson thank you Charlie